feel like there is a difference between
online friends and
let's say real friends okay because you
know i say this as someone who
has met most of my friends online and
has
found my fiance online you know what i
mean like
i will say that they didn't feel like
real friends like
until i saw them in real life i feel
like that's like sealing the deal
because a lot there's there's something
about having online friends where
there's always that wall of like how
well do i really know this person you
know what i mean and
you could there has been like plenty of
times where i've like connected with
them
immediately you know you guys being like
some of them yeah and then there are
equally as many times when i've meet
them in real life and they're just like
wow you were not high and this is weird
now and i feel we've all been there you
know what i mean
and i feel like if you just have that
that first step where it is where it is
just the online relationship you're
missing out on
a big part of what it is to you know be
friends and be social and everything
like that
i mean i've always been since like
[ __ ] age 12 i would happily get on
[ __ ] voice chat and talk to like
[ __ ] 30 year old man why did i do
that that's uh yeah that sounds
like the context
zombies right i would i would gladly get
on the [ __ ] mic and like
i would like bully these 30 year old men
like like i didn't give a [ __ ] dude when
i was 12 i would gladly like shout at
people like i would be
no i didn't have that man well i like
the like your anger i like the comments
i said dude
i'm a walking coin flip someone said you
asked for danny g yeah
that was okay no joke right my little
brother was
was too scared to argue people online so
when you did start to argue with people
online and i was in the other room i'd
be like
give me the [ __ ] headset i'm gonna
argue you play so i would [ __ ] shout
at them for him
yeah because he couldn't do it good and
he would lose the arguments i'm like
you're not losing the arguments on my
account right
over my [ __ ] dead body do you think i
will allow you to lose this
i don't know i would just because it's
one of those things right where
i would not fall for [ __ ] when i was
like
12 or 13 yeah the [ __ ] that they were
trying to pull right
for some reason i knew what was
happening most of the time when i was
aware
because even from like what's happening
i was [ __ ] playing zombies with them
most of the time mostly
chill yeah it was all good i mean i
don't know i think it was it was weird
back then because
it just started when everyone started
voice chatting yeah i think it was new
yeah and it wasn't really weird yet now
it's weird if you do i think it's super
weird but back then i didn't think of it
as that weird yeah when i was a kid
but maybe sure i mean back then it was
like this new thing and now
with so many [ __ ] weird stories
coming out you've got to be yeah
now it's not you know if i had a 12 year
old kid and i hadn't talked to a 30 old
man
i i'd like be like what the [ __ ] you
doing yeah yeah but like
you know i i get why people have a lot
of online friends it's because
most of the time people search for
online friends because they don't find
that connection
oh yeah but
it's the same thing i would say as like
you know when you you can have like the
best friends in the world
but as soon as like you move in with
each other and live in the same house
that
that like change can change a lot of
dynamics you know what i mean
especially you know you meet someone
especially in [ __ ] uni
you meet some people you think are chill
as soon as you move in with each other
you start hating each other
yeah that's true and you see all their
little [ __ ] ticks and stuff that just
get on your nerves
i mean there was like a i mean i've
basically been raised
like on the internet right like ever
since like age like 11. i was playing
runescape i was doing [ __ ] on miniclip
like yeah
i was all and i always did not mind
talking to strangers because i always
thought like
i'm not going to give any personal
information you know i i never did for
some reason i was smart enough to never
do anything like that
yeah um and there must have been a good
chunk maybe maybe like a year in my life
where i pretty much only spoke to online
people like friends that i
thought were like my friends yeah it
must have been the maybe first year of
university
it's really weird i've i never had a
concept of an online friend until i
started youtube
yeah like i never would get on to like i
feel like we were two different sides of
like the coins
yeah i i was always like i would always
go on cause because in my head i was
like why would i talk to this random
person online when i have
irrelevance to talk to you well that's
this oh that's the way
you go joey's here's where it gets sad i
didn't at the time
and the thing is that you think oh this
is like because i used to see those
those things on twitter because back
then you should see these things like
irl uh online friends or real friends
yeah mom you don't get it you know yeah
yeah back when tumblr was like you know
pink tumbler yeah yeah
and i used to totally agree with that
because i was like i was 16 and that's
all i had and then
after i like actually actually got real
friends i was like
oh this is what normal friendship
like it's like totally different yeah
it's something that like i don't think
you realize kind of affects you because
you totally think you're fine and
i think you can be well adjusted sort of
if you have
only online friends but it's a lot
harder yeah because i feel like having
that that irl
uh kind of interaction to ground you and
make sure you're not doing weird things
and you're you know
that you're interacting in a healthy way
right i mean because the thing about
only having online friends is that
inevitably you are just living in
your own bubble it is an online bubble
right yeah
and you live through what you present to
them yeah exactly right you're only
presenting
one side of yourself for the best side
of yourself you're not seeing every side
of a person
so inevitably if you just live in a
bubble you know you might luck out and
be like okay this is actually a healthy
nice
nicely balanced bubble but you know most
of the time
you're missing some kind of that social
interaction yeah
social connection that you just don't
get online unfortunately
and i also think because i made a lot of
the friends through gaming
yeah a lot of the time how you were as
friends was dependent on
how you were in the game right right and
obviously i was normally really good at
the games
yeah so i was normally like yeah i'm
kind of i'm kind of cool
you know and it was one of those things
where online when i saw these people
like i was like
to those friends i was respected and
they thought wow this guy's so cool
you know he just does his own thing and
yeah but in real life i was a [ __ ]
loser
and it kind of made this dichotomy in my
head where i'm like yeah i'm funny yeah
i'm charming and then i go meet up with
people and i [ __ ] struggle
like i couldn't i didn't know how to
because i hadn't really i wasn't very
well adjusted
yeah and it made me think a lot and
makes me look back and i don't know it's
like how do you convince someone when
they're in that
to see it like when they're in that
sense of i only have online friends how
do you make them see that maybe that
it's not a healthy relate like it's not
very healthy because to them they might
be perfectly happy and fine right and
that's the thing i think it's just a
matter of perspective right because to
them that's all they know
yeah so i don't think um until they
actually experience the other side
of like trying to begin and start and
maintain
irl friends yeah they just won't know
they'll be like why would i do that when
this is so much easier and more
comfortable that's right and also i
realized as well that like
when i was predominantly spending all my
time online it felt like i could never
make any progress
in my life because i i was not investing
anything in
real life right i was maybe i'd go to
work yeah and i'd go home but that was
about it right i never made any
investment
elsewhere right i felt like my life
stagnated because of that
because i didn't you know i think when
you make friends i didn't seek out
something else
right right because when you make
friends irl it's not just that it's like
you miss out on a lot of opportunities
in general like because you're not
putting yourself out there you're not
you're not you know
maybe other jobs you might hear about
you know oth you miss out on a lot of
things i think yeah
yeah and it's not just as simple as
having friends and having friends it's
like there's a lot of stuff that comes
with having our old friends yeah
yeah and like you know i don't know it's
it's it's really made me think a lot
recently especially because like moving
to japan as well it's really made me
think a lot